hey you guys this is devon from big
brother all stars and this is my
et post eviction interview 21 seasons of
winners and not one of those faces look
like
mine so when i walked through those
doors i had that desire that
determination to be the very first
face to give hope to those behind me who
have the desire to come in here and play
this game
because not seeing a face that looks
like mine is very discouraging
it's hurtful and it does make me feel
like maybe it's impossible
i tried to make sure throughout the
season to
educate whenever i had the opportunity
to do so with the housemates
also because i knew live feeds were on
and i wanted those watching at home to
be able to get that education
as well and so that was
my mission in those conversations to get
a lot of them to be
aware because i would hear certain
dialogues certain conversations and i'm
like
i can do one of two things one i can
bash you because
you're talking crazy or two i can take
this moment to educate you and i think
that's where a lot of people fall
short when it comes to this movement
they don't take the time to educate
people they just say
oh you don't get it and they throw them
away or you don't get it and then they
slander them
let me educate you so now that i've
given you this knowledge and i've
deposited it
into you you have no more excuses
there's no room to say i didn't know
or i didn't know now you know so i'm
holding people accountable and i'm
having the conversations
and making people aware i was sicker
than people i was ready to go
like i was sicker than people i loved
this game
but sometimes being in there it's just
it's a lot it's a lot and you know me
julie i'm too real and the fakeness i
can't do and so
after seven weeks i'm like look this
fake man's gotta go on retirement i'm
tired
i'm tired
oh my gosh where do i begin the list is
it it goes it goes tyler is very fake to
me
i didn't appreciate how he came to
bailey and i
and told us that you know he wanted to
self-evict and throw himself to
christmas
so that she can put him up as a
replacement nom
and i get that that might have been
strategy or whatever but what bothered
me
is he said you two both deserve to be
here i understand why you here i get the
black lives matter movement so i'm gonna
do this
to show you guys that i am an ally
that's what bothered me
don't use the movement for strategic
purposes in this game
so that he is top for me i got caught in
the middle of
this lie where i had to vote ian out of
the house
i'm so sorry davon i just really hope
you'll give me a chance outside this
house to
be friends because i really love you as
a person
absolutely you know it's a game she is
going to have
to have a moment to be educated as well
because
you know i understand she had to do a
game move
but i asked her privately hey on a
personal level i as a black woman
do not want to be on this show bashing
a black man for something he didn't even
do i said so if you did it and i even
gave her an
out i said hey nicole you know if you
freaked out at the last minute and
decided to flip your boat
your vote that's cool let me know that
but don't have me out here
publicly bashing this man like help me
out in that department
and the fact that she couldn't do that
i don't know me and her like to have a
long conversation because that i'm
really bothered by that but it's still
fresh you know what i'm saying who knows
what's gonna happen when the game is
over right now it's really fresh
and so right now i have a major problem
with her
like i told him in the house i am so
sorry
like there are no words to explain how
sorry i am
you know for not trusting him and
being vocal about that i am definitely
apologetic
however it's not like i just pulled it
out of the sky
you know throughout this time david has
went out of his way to sabotage my game
and has confessed to it and so the level
of
trust was not there there was no trust
between us so a move like that
was kind of perfect when it came to he
and i because the foundation was so
it was the trust foundation was terrible
but
i am deeply apologizing from the bottom
of my heart
and i hope that he can forgive me and i
hope that we can be friends afterwards
[Music]
just a phone call call me i love this
game i'm gonna play
if they call me every single time until
i win
like i come into the house and of course
you know we complain oh my god we're
here
it's this is that but i love the game
all aspects of it though the competition
level the
meeting different people the messiness
that's about to occur i love all of it
and i would have those moments inside of
the house i would find myself
battling as a house guest versus a fan
and i'm like as a viewer
i want to say this but as a house guest
i have to shut up
and so it was just i love this game i
play it over and over
i would love to see tyler i would love
to see nicole
i would love to see memphis i would love
to i would love to see everybody except
david danny and chris
i mean david danny and kevin that's it
all of them can come
let's go speed it up cigar be the glory
for second chances i love this game i
love being black and i just
love everything right now give me a
margarita i'm ready to go
i did not but i got my moscato hey i'm
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay